تصاعد حده الحرب في اوكرانيا لا يزيد كياب
موسكو الا اسرارا على تقويه جيشيهما سواء
بالعداد او بالافراد ليعطي مؤشرا واضحا
على حرب طويله الامل فاذا كانت اوكرانيا
تلحوا على حلفائها الغربيين بامدادها
بالاسلحه فان روسيا تسارع الخطا لتعزيز
صفوف جيشها وزير الدفاع الروسي سريع شيكو
واعلن رفعت اعداد القوات المسلحه الروسيه
ليصل الى مليون ونصف المليون جندي في
الفتره ما بين 2023 و 2026 ما يعني ان
الجيش الروسي سيضم ما يناهز 400,000 جندي
خلال السنوات الثلاثه المقبله
ومنذ بدايه العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه ظلت موسكو تعمل على
تعزيز الصفوف قواتها بعناصر اضافيه ودعم
الجيش الروسي
بصفوفه ضم اليه افراد من المجموعه فاكنار
الخاصه فضلا عن مقاتلين من الشيشان دون ان
ننسى المجندين الذين تم ضمهم خلال عمليه
التجنيد الواسعه التي اطلقت في وقت السابع
[موسيقى]